e aí galera que atingiu o planalto com
vocês como vocês podem ver não estou no
meu quarto né estou em fernando de
noronha a aae eu vou aproveitar essa
paisagem linda demais a mostrar minha
música nova pra vocês pode ser tão já
peço logo no início que quem gosta da
música por favor clique no gosto e sei
que é uma forma de me ajudar no que eu
faço no trabalho entendeu essa música
pra você que um dia que estava uma
pessoa não pode estar com ela o desejou
muito uma coisa e não conseguiu ter
sucesso você já sentiu isso eu gosto de
uma pessoa que está longe porque essa
música e hoje essa música se gostar
clique não gostei é nós
é
o beijo que eu nunca te dei
prometo ainda vou te dar
o dia que eu te encontrar
eu vou te encontrar não sei
prometeu monte procurar todo linda que
eu passar pra te trazer de volta um
lugar onde você não vê o passasse ao
meio ansioso feito cá quando entra fecha
a porta a porta tudo eu tô freio nem
acredito que você propõe tbk beijo que
eu nunca te dei no metok na ponte da
judia que o dia encontrar
eu vou te encontrar não sei
prometeu vou te procurar o douro já que
eu passar aqui pra te trazer de volta o
lugar onde você não vê o lançasse ao meu
onze poder tocar quando em casa fecha a
porta
o botafogo eu tô feio nem acredito que
você nem eu
agora eu vou poder te pegar
a loja vai pensar na pessoa aquela
pessoa ligada
eu sei que você sabe aquela pessoa que
pensa agora tá comigo fechou ó ó
vejo que eu nunca te dei prometo ainda
vou te dar
eu vou te encontrar não sei
prometeu vou te procurar o dono daqui eu
passar
desde então tá te dei
prometo aí não vou ditar o dia que eu te
encontrar seu motivo pra não sei
prometeu vou te procurar
todo lugar que eu faço
eu já te encontrei
quando você vai gostar da música você
clica em gostei